everybody got one word for you
B in mashed potatoes that's not one word
okay so I'm gonna dump demo of eating
mashed potatoes that's in our joycie
cookbook so what I have here is I have
some red organic potatoes that I boil
until just done you can see the fork
goes in very easily I'm gonna leave the
skins on put a little bit of olive oil
in the bottom of the pan and I'm gonna
put it back on a medium heat you don't
have them up first no I cut them up
after I get a minute so let's get a min
thank you okay so what I'm gonna do is I
really just have it on low low medium
heat start to cut the potatoes okay
these skins make it more nutritious okay
great really easily and again they eat
is just helping get a little bit more of
the fluid and the moisture from boiling
the potatoes we don't want to question
if you want it you can take the skins
off I just like to leave them on if you
use a russet potato you're gonna need to
remove the skins so the red potato is
left work also a gold Yukon with a thin
skin is less work and that's important
to me yes you had a question this recipe
includes potatoes yes okay so about a
quarter cup of olive oil
all right like my quarter cup measuring
stick because you can help do these very
fast and loose with the exact on the
exact measurement yeah well I just used
to doing it a lot so I kind of know what
it is okay 3/4 closet vegenaise and
generous with the sea salt it's to taste
but um potatoes soak up a lot so we'll
put the herbs in
and let's just mix that up and see how
it looks
again this is one of the dishes that we
eat on a weekly basis okay I love this
and I eat this all the time it's a great
like post-training
something like that and it's also super
easy to make sea salt don't forget the
fact you can make okay and you know
please keep in mind that we are eating
drinking too super food drinks a day so
if we were to go vegan and decide that
we were gonna eat vegan mashed potatoes
all day long that's not the mortgage on
this isn't exactly locale again like
this is okay I just put a half a
teaspoon of ground pepper in and the
consistency looks perfect it looks
exactly like the measurement completely
correct and we've got vegan mashed
potatoes if you want to make it pretty
can I say one thing yes this is what you
want on your Thanksgiving
okay so some nice dill again our kids
little kids they don't like the dill in
it so I don't always add it if you want
it to that's a child that's Jaya re-roll
okay so there you have it this is about
the size of spoon at which ants how many
how many would that serve open over
myself just stick it right up
[Laughter]
[Music]